i love your red hair i really do
i love yours it's so great you've got a
bigger quiff than i do though
yeah there's some special stuff i've got
mayonnaise in there and
[Applause]
wax nice i like it i have a whole steel
structure yeah
something about conan yeah there's just
something about me uh
now did you get some people get i know
in in the uk they say
ginger they're starting to say that here
now but when i was growing up no one
ever said ginger
yeah i was just like hey redhead and
then bang
[Applause]
but but you know for you it was you know
be ginger right
yeah ginger and i feel like over here
being being a redhead is a really cool
thing you've got like the fiery red hair
and everyone loves it and then
back at home everyone's like you're a
ginger and you have no soul has anyone
ever heard that
i've heard i've had no soul but not
because i'm a ginger right
oh right yeah it's usually when he's
closing an orphanage
yeah yeah yeah that'll do it hey if it's
not making money i gotta shut it down
exactly
but i'm just you know like they're yeah
it sounds like they're rough on
redheads or gingers in the uk like
there's a there's a day wasn't there
like a national
kick a ginger date pick a ginger day
yeah what the hell is that all about
i know i'm not even natural ginger and i
dyed my hair for the show
and then like i came into school and
they were like happy
national kick a ginger day and then just
like started kicking me and i was like
thanks guys
it was my friends it was okay it was
yeah bullying it's always okay to be
kicked viciously by your friend yeah
yeah uh you know it's funny because when
sansa first
game of thrones startup and sansa first
appeared as a character
she was a bit misunderstood the
character was a little misunderstood you
think by fans and so you would
experience that because
fans would sometimes not be so nice to
you is that right yeah
this is just going to be stories of like
how oppressed i am
um this is like therapy this is therapy
yeah only it's a little less expensive
yeah i'm gonna just take a lighthouse
yeah
um yeah i
i i one time went out with maisie who
plays arya on the show
yeah yes and um
we we went out to like a shopping mall
and this guy came over and he
he he came over to maisie and he was
like i love you i love you so much
you're amazing in the show and and it
was it was starting to turn into quite a
long conversation and i was like
should i just turn away like hide my
face like this is kind of awkward
but then i was like you know what he's
probably just gonna see me in a second
and be like i love you and i was like oh
god here we go
um and then and then he was like
could you could you take a photo of
maisie and i for me
and i was like yeah sure clearly he just
hasn't recognized me yet
and then he was like sorry i really just
you're not that great yeah i don't like
you what
and i was like what the hell yeah i want
to fight that guy
thank you i wanted to fight him but it
wasn't kickaging today so yeah i know
that that's terrible no i yeah this guy
was just but that's they get your
characters confused with with you with
who you are yeah it's crazy
i mean i've had a lot of like oh lady
sansa nice to meet you
okay you're not the character you're not
the character on the game of thrones
no i'm not actually her
he's heartbroken sorry you do it so well
oh thank you for sure
yeah that you were the character yeah so
i'm a bit late sophia's actually had it
much
tougher than sansa it's been a hard life
yeah yeah but conan you are conan no no
i'm an actor named chip whitley